it was july 2007 and the dry new mexico
heat could shrivel your average outsider
into the size of a small keychain
melinda and bailey two young women
dressed in impeccable costumes of the
harry potter characters luna lovegood
and hermione granger were getting ready
for a momentous event the release of
harry potter and the deathly hallows the
final installment in the epic saga of
the boy wizard and his quest to defeat
the evil lord voldemort they like so
many other cosplaying fans had driven
out to page one books an exquisite
bookstore in the very heart of
albuquerque it was miles from where the
two of them had lived but more than
worth the drive to be part of the
potterhead fever long before the series
author would lose her mind on twitter
and make the books a lot harder for most
people to enjoy trans rights by the way
bayley and melinda were counting the
seconds until the bookstore's doors
finally opened and they could get the
answers to so many of their burning
questions why had snape killed
dumbledore would harry ron and hermione
find and destroy the last few horcruxes
allowing them to finally destroy lord
voldemort once and for all and most
importantly of all would their ships
sail mel was harry hermione all the way
but bayley controversially was all about
ron and draco the two of them couldn't
be more excited to be part of literary
history like this the bookstore's doors
opened and little by little the line fed
in it was worth the long drive in the
late evening and facing the sweltering
summer heat when the two of them were
holding copies of harry potter and the
deathly hallows and walking back to
their car they knew it had all been
worth it mel thought this must have been
how jesus felt when he finished writing
the first edition of the old testament
history incidentally had never been
mel's strong suit melinda and bailey set
off back to their homes in the sticks
bailey was driving she'd been kind
enough to give mel a lift knowing they
were probably their neighborhood's
biggest potterheads it warmed their
hearts to see all this enthusiasm for
the book series they loved so fondly
seeing so many others in costume or with
vinyl decals or bumper stickers in their
cars declaring their love of the
franchise they'd seen hagrid grabbing a
mocha in starbucks maddiy moody had been
filling up his buick at the gas and gulp
and cirrus black had passed out from
heat stroke and needed to be attended to
medically with an all-black costume in
this kind of weather that much was
basically inevitable as bayley and
melinda continued their drive drawing
closer to the witchy wilderness of
cibola national forest they continued
sharing their thoughts feelings and
predictions about the book to come they
couldn't wait to read it was it even
possible for someone to be this amped
about a book their enthusiasm was so
great they didn't even notice on those
long winding back roads that another car
had started following them it was 8 15
pm now pitch black the kind of darkness
where bad things happen evidently during
a lull in the conversation
mel turned her eyes up to the rear-view
mirror and spotted the car behind them
it was a car they'd recognize anywhere a
turquoise blue ford anglia 105e to some
this would be a mostly unrecognizable if
a little old-fashioned car but to
melinda and bailey it could only ever be
the enchanted vehicle of arthur weasley
the father of series mainstay ron
weasley the car which had become iconic
since being featured in the books and
films was able to fly and turn invisible
and had gotten the main characters both
into and out of a variety of amusing
screams mel told bailey to take a look
and she couldn't help but chuckle in
admiration plenty of harry potter fans
were in town tonight and some took it
further than others at times bailey
wondered if her three harry potter
bumper stickers reading my other ride is
a nimbus 2000 save gas take the night
bus and all aboard the hogwarts express
respectively were a little excessive and
then there was whoever this was whose
intense harry potter fandom led them to
buy an authentic harry potter car
neither bailey nor mel could make out
the driver the car's windshield was
slightly fogged up strange strange
seeing as it was such a hot evening out
they noticed that the car also must have
had broken turn signals because anytime
the car needed to make a turn the
driver's arm would slide out the window
and make the appropriate gesture the
ford anglia kept pace with them
following them at every single turn it
was only then that they noticed
something a little odd the car didn't
have a license plate it was almost as
though all identifying features for the
car or its driver had been obscured
bayley who was getting a little nervous
at this point decided to try out a
little experiment at the next three
intersections she took three left turns
it seemed improbable that anyone would
actually intend to take a route that
would lead them in a circle and yet the
ford anglia did just that bailly's most
frightening suspicion was confirmed they
were being followed she didn't need to
tell melinda seeing as the bad vibes
radiating off the car were already
palpable the two assessed their options
they couldn't drive home after all the
last thing you'd want is a crazy person
knowing where you live their best bet
was to drive to a heavily populated area
say the center of albuquerque during one
of the most highly anticipated book
launches in recent memory or better yet
the local police station whoever was
driving this car wouldn't dare try
anything there bailey and melinda sped
up and took off in the direction of the
city but to their horror the ford anglia
sped up in kind bailly was pressing the
gas pedal down to the floorboards and
still the ford anglia gained its
headlights glowing like menacing white
eyes in an instant it pulled ahead of
them the driver's hand emerging once
again this time it signaled for them to
stop the two of them would sooner drive
their car off a cliff than stop for
whoever was behind the murky front
window of the ford anglia as the ford
began to slow perhaps hoping to box them
in bailey pounded on the gas again and
lurch forward weaving around the ford
and passing it once more their two
copies of harry potter and the deathly
hallows were rattling around in the back
seats neither bailey nor melinda
expected this night to end in a car
chase but it wouldn't be the last time
their expectations would be dashed
before sunrise the two potterheads were
in the lead again but it would still be
seven or eight miles before they were
officially out of cibola national forest
bailey drove as fast as she could she
and melinda were frantic messes of
terror and adrenaline now but the ford
anglia kept moving gaining on them with
every second that passed go faster god
damn it faster melinda screamed in
horror i'm going as fast as i can bailey
yelped back the car merged into the lane
next to them and sped forward again they
were neck and neck now but it was still
too dark inside the other car to make
out the driver just as mel was wishing
that she could have a closer look her
wish was granted in the worst way
possible the fort anglia abruptly moved
to the side and slammed against them
knocking them off course with a sudden
shocking blow the shock knocked bailey
sideways in the car and yanked the
steering wheel along with them the car
veered off the side of the road and
tumbled down the grassy embankment
towards the trees taking the two
unfortunate potterheads down with it
before they knew it their fender was
wrapped around the trunk of a ponderosa
pine tree if it wasn't for their
seatbelts and airbags they would have
died instantly but perhaps in the end
that would have been a mercy melinda and
bailey sat up as the airbags deflated in
front of them the car was totaled as the
two of them shakely unbuckled their seat
belts and climbed out of the car they
were bathed in the light of the ford
anglia's headlights from above as though
they were about to be abducted by a
ufo's tractor beam the ford was just
waiting on the road above them the
tension rumbled like a low beastial
growl the driver was still obscured
behind the foggy windshield but their
arm was hanging out of the window once
more
bailey and melinda were too frightened
in days by the crash to even move as the
car began advancing with unnatural grace
down the embankment before them it
clambered towards them with such uncanny
intent that it seemed almost like it had
a mind of its own rather than a machine
being piloted by a human being melinda
pointed forwards and screamed she saw
something bailey didn't there was
something on the outstretched palm of
the driver's hand she thought it was a
tattoo at first until she saw it move
two human eyes were fixed into the
center of the flesh staring directly at
her like a crustacean's eyes on stalks
moments later the car was upon them and
melinda's scream was silenced a
concerned passerby found bayley's
abandoned car crashed in the ditch
beside the road the next morning the two
women were never found and two bashed up
copies of harry potter and the deathly
hallows were discovered on the car's
floor among all the shards of broken
glass never to be read some days can be
magical just not in the ways you would
have hoped especially if you run afoul
of scp-3470
a euclid-class anomaly somewhat cruelly
nicknamed harry potter's revenge sadly
kidnappings and car accidents aren't
that uncommon in this strange scary
world we live in but at a certain point
the scp foundation's many field agents
detected a strange pattern in a series
of car accidents near sebola national
forest in new mexico in all these
instances the cars had been found
crashed but there were never any bodies
eagle-eyed police officers studying the
crash also picked up another more subtle
detail in all these events the cars had
turquoise blue paint chips on them even
if the cars themselves weren't blue
suggesting the impact of another car
foundation eggheads correlated this with
another strange report they'd received
out of new mexico a young couple had
narrowly avoided a dangerous incident
when a car matching the description of a
classic fort anglia 105e tried to flag
them down on a dark and lonely road near
sebola national forest just like bailey
and melinda the duo were unable to see
the driver behind the fogged-up
windshield however when they got close
enough to see the driver's hand they
both attested that it had eyes on its
palm describing it as similar to the
terrifying pale man from the movie pan's
labyrinth with all these frightening and
clearly anomalous data points in place
the scp foundation decided it was time
to do their due diligence and go on the
hunt for this predatory car it wouldn't
be the first time they'd tackled a
sadistic or carnivorous vehicle and
because of this experience they weren't
going in unprepared there was of course
as cp 2086 also known as the man-eating
bus these were a species of huge
insect-like creatures who'd evolved to
perfectly mimic your average city bus in
order to lure prey into their bodies
another notable instance was scp-1386
also known as the living ice cream van
this being is even more mysterious than
the man eating buses and boasts a wide
range of abilities from a hazardous form
to a fleshy appendage somewhat similar
to the arm emerging from scp-3470
the jury's still out on whether either
of these anomalies are in any way
directly connected to scp-3470
but it gave the scp foundation a few
ideas on how exactly to engage study and
potentially even contain this new
vehicular slaughterer of man as you've
probably come to expect by this point
where there are still so many unknown
variables involved the foundation
decided to fall back on old faithful
throwing a couple of d-classes at it and
just seeing what happened two were
selected placed in a standard foundation
off-road vehicle with dash and rear cams
and given a variety of equipment
including a special semi-automatic
assault rifle with armor-piercing rounds
each one containing a micro gps that
would allow the foundation to continue
tracking
scp-3470 after initial contact and if in
the process of the experiment
scp-3470 revealed some frightening new
powers then a standard vehicle and a
pair of d-classes weren't much of a loss
once again another hapless duo were sent
off on the roads in the proximity of
cibola national park though the
foundation hoped these two would at
least end the night accounted for they
patrolled the roads once or twice
remarking on the beauty on the stars
above while not much of anything
happened command kept close tabs on them
back at the nearest containment site
feeding orders through earpieces and
watching the live video feeds as the
drive continued the two d-classes
finally encountered scp-3470
they get closer at which point scp-347
begins its typical pattern of hunting
behavior it merged onto the road next to
the d-class vehicle and began to slide
alongside them that's when the two
d-classes realized and couldn't help but
remark that this looked just like the
car from harry potter was hogwarts
school of witchcraft and wizardry a new
group of interests now had lord
voldemort entered into an allegiance
with the scarlet king this was hilarious
of course it didn't remain all that
funny to the d-classes for long the
anomalous ford anglia suddenly pulled up
in front of them and ground to an abrupt
halt forcing the d-class driving to
pound the brakes startling both of them
that's when the human arm slithered out
from the anglia's open window and made
the stop signal before twisting around
and revealing the two staring human eyes
embedded in its palm the d-classes
started to panic and reverse away while
the car started chasing them at
terrifying speeds foundation command
kept ordering the d-class riding shotgun
to live up to his title and blast the
vehicle with one of the tracking bullets
but the driver was so terrified he
refused to slow down and give his fellow
d-class a clear shot as a result the arm
d-class released a flurry of shots and
just got lucky that some of them
happened to strike the car this caused
it to let out a terrible pain shriek
comparable to the squeal of breaking car
tires
scp-3470 then retreated allowing the
d-classes to safely return to base while
command tracked the ford anglia back to
its native habitat it was time for the
next phase of the mission to begin the
foundation brought in mobile task force
lambda 12 also known as the pest
controllers a group of operatives who
specialize in taking down particularly
verminous creatures they'd be the ones
to track down scp-3470's
nest and find out what they were really
up against here in order to complete the
mission four members of the task force
were designated for infiltration while
two others were designated to keep watch
outside the infiltrators were given
reinforced armor and a wide selection of
weapons and tools including a
flamethrower a tranquilizer gun a net
gun and a light machine gun
scp-3470s movements were tracked back to
a cave in sabola national forest when
the infiltration team entered they saw
track marks with a familiar tire tread
on the floor and walls of the cave which
suggested a number of frightening things
about the anomaly they were chasing as
they got deeper into the cave the air
became intensely hot and humid they
found scat piles filled with human bones
and a local sheriff's badge suggesting
that the car does indeed eat and digest
its prey but most terrifying of all the
infiltration team discovered a number of
translucent eggs which had small
quadrupedal organisms assumed to be the
larval stage of scp-3470
wriggling away inside they collected
some of the eggs and then burned the
rest before turning around to leave
that's when they noticed that
scp-3470 was in the cave mouth waiting
for them except this one wasn't
turquoise like the other this one was
black the car began revving aggressively
after a tense standoff in which one of
the task force members muttered i
refused to be killed by a goddamn ford
the task force member with the light
machine gun opened fire on the car's
exposed arm one of the bullets hit the
creature in one of its hand eyes causing
it to let out another pain shriek and
retreat from the cave mouth allowing the
task force to finally escape the two who
were meant to be on the lookout were
never seen again
scp-3470 remains at large with the pest
controllers doing whatever they can to
track it down and contain it the eggs
are also subject to further study in the
meantime be careful who you stop for
because if you end up inside this
magical ford anglia an encounter with
the whomping willow is going to be the
least of your worries now go check out
scp-1958 magic bus and living ice cream
van scp-1386
for more villainous vehicles from the
world of the scp foundation